the weather conditions have changed in
the last half an hour the wind has
started
to come in from a different direction
it's got very hot it's around
40 degrees celsius where we are and
actually more resources being sent into
this area because the changing weather
conditions do mean the risk
is much higher and this is one of three
areas of greece that has experienced the
biggest
fires in the last week and it's where 21
british firefighters
have come to help and offer support and
we've joined them today they've invited
us to see
what they're doing and at the moment uh
there's a team
behind me who are just clearing this
area to provide some sort of barrier
uh for the fire to stop it spreading
from one side of this woodland
to another now i should say it was
around this time of day yesterday that
a fire took hold pretty quickly and they
had to pull back and we've been warned
to keep our eyes out but that is
very much a risk at the moment let me
just introduce ian
irving to you the incident commander
here thanks very much indeed for
speaking to us
ian how are things going so far yeah
yeah they're going very well we're
working in collaboration with our great
colleagues and as you'll see behind
we've got crews creating a fire break
here
we've been tasked by the greek fire and
rescue to create this fire break so
we're working under their command
systems and their control
and their and their affordance all of
the welfare facilities that we needed
obviously in these hot conditions that
we're experiencing now there's 21 of you
here
from six different forces back home in
england and south wales
how did it feel when you got the call to
come out here oh well we're all pr we
feel privileged to be able to come out
and help um
we're tasked by the home secretary uh
pretty early on to
uh our equipment to come across here and
help our greek colleagues who
really feel privileged from fire and
rescue service across the uk to assist
in this
in these unprecedented times here in
greece at the moment
certainly is i mean these are the worst
wildfires they've seen in
a long time do you think this is going
to be more of what you're doing in the
future fighting wildfires
not in the uk but internationally well i
think climate change is
is proving that evidence that we're
having more fun and more wildfires so
this may be a thing of the future that
that's looked at across europe
and how concerned are you um at the
conditions at the moment well we've got
we've got our safety procedures in place
we've got tactical lookouts for wind
change
uh heat and humidity so we've got we've
got it all risk assessment work within
our control
control parameters so i'm comfortable at
the moment and we'll we'll constantly
constantly monitor that as will we
rotate crews so they're not overwhelmed
with the heat and the humidity
ian we wish you all the best thank you
very much indeed for speaking to us and
inviting us along today
i should say this is three of the
biggest
areas that are being focused on uh by uh
more than 20 countries in terms of uh
firefighting support uh the big fire
just outside athens where we were uh
yesterday and the day before that has
now subsided
at the island of elvia where we saw the
most concerning fires in the last week
well
fires that they thought were in
remission have now picked up again
and here this area is certainly becoming
a focus
uh there's fires there's certainly a
large fire threat
we're seeing smoke in certain pockets in
this area
and as i said before they can pick up
and take hold very quickly
so we're going to hand back to you and
keep across the situation here